Hey guys i'm Grant Thompson the King of Random
I just released a video on my YouTube channel about the stealth shelf which is a DIY concealment shelf
It'll let you hide money, passports, firearms or anything else that you want out of sight and out of mind.
If you maneuver some of the decorations on top into just the right position you can press the bottom of the shelf
And it will open up revealing your secret stash inside.
Now, I designed this to be a DIY project that you could do at home with your own tools materials
But I have had an unprecedented number of requests to sell these things
I've heard your requests and I put together a team that right now is in the process of manufacturing these things
So we can make them available to you
So I know a lot of you are DIYers, but I know a lot of you have two main problems
One, You don't have the tools to make the projects and two you don't have the time. So, in this kickstarter
we're going to solve both of those challenges for you by offering three different variations of this product. We've got three different packages
You can choose from. The first one is for someone who likes to tinker and do things themselves. All of the materials will come pre-manufactured.
All the boards are already cut to size the holes for the hinges are already drilled
you just need to assemble it together .The second package comes pre-assembled for you
It's a basic shelf
But you can get it in a light stain a dark stain or no stain at all so you can choose your own color.
This is put together for you and ship ready to mount straight to your wall. The only thing
it doesn't have are the bells and whistles and that's the third package
This is the premium shelf like the one you see in my shop
It comes with multiple locks diamond plate aluminum trim magnetic locking options and the magnetic motion activated LED
Now come check this out if you look at the side of the shelf here
You can see this actually flush against the wall, as I open the shelf it moves up out of position
And it never actually makes contact [with] the wall through the entire cycle
It's called a floating shelf, and it looks really elegant and really decorative now in this particular shelf
I just have a (BB) gun which actually has some magnetic locks on itself for my CO2 (Carbon-dioxide) cartridges, and it's also got a removable
Led light you can use as a makeshift flashlight in the event of emergency
Or if you have intruders you want to go check them out
you've got easy access to everything right there. When you're ready to get back to hiding your item simply move your
decorations back out of position and press the bottom back into position. You're back in stealth mode just like that
You can't lose your keys because there aren't any the keys are the decorations themselves
And you can quite literally put your keys into any decorations you want
But you still have to go the secret magnetic location to get to open
Which makes it very very difficult for children to open, but the stealth shelf isn't limited to concealing firearms think about spare money
Or cash you might have around the house that you don't want people getting into it's also a good place to store
Passports or spare keys because it'll just sit there until you need them. You have full control with the stealth shelf
What goes in what comes out and who knows about it now for me? I've put these in my workshop
I put them in my bedroom you can put them by your front door you can basically put them wherever you want to access something quickly
It comes in a couple different designs
So it'll nicely complement the decor you already have in your home, and at a price point
it's very competitive with floating shelves that are already on the market
So if you get the value of having a stealth shelf in your home
Then back the project now choose the kit that makes the most sense for you
And you'll be one of the first to have one. I'm doing this for you guys
I'm excited to see King of Random products in your home. Thanks for making this reality
I'll see you in the next video. Talk to you then.